so
in this video we're going to see how to
load and fine-tune
a pre-trained model it's very quick and
if you've watched our pipeline videos
which i'll link below the process is
very similar
this time though we're going to be using
transfer learning
and doing some training ourselves rather
than just loading a model and using it
as
is like we did in the pipeline videos so
if you to learn more about transfer
learning if you don't know much about it
you can head to the
what is transfer learning video and i'll
link that below as well
but for now let's look at this code so
to start we pick which model we want to
use
in this case we're going to use the
famous classic bert
but what does this this line here this
monstrosity this
tf auto model for sequence
classification what does that mean
well the tf stands for tensorflow and
the rest means
take a language model and stick a
sequence classification head onto it if
it doesn't have one already
so what we're going to do here is load
bert which is a general language general
purpose language model that doesn't have
a sequence classification head
we're going to use the from pre-trained
method and that method ensures that all
our weights come from the pre-trained
model
so they're not randomly initialized with
the exception of the new sequence
classification head we're going to add
so this method needs to know two things
firstly it needs to know the name of the
model you wanted to load
and secondly it needs to know how many
classes your problem has
so if you want to follow along with the
data from our data sets videos which
i'll link below
then you'll have two classes positive
and negative and thus num labels equals
two
but what about this compile thing so if
you're familiar with keras you've
probably seen this already
but if not this is one of the core
methods in keras you always need to
compile your model before you train it
compile needs to know two things firstly
the loss function which is basically
what are we trying to optimize
and here we import the sparse
categorical cross cross-entropy loss
function
so that's a mouthful if you've never
encountered it before
but it's the standard loss function for
any neural network that's doing a
classification task
it basically encourages the network to
output large values so large
probabilities for the right class
and low values of low probabilities for
the wrong classes
note that you can specify the loss
function as a string like we do with the
optimizer here
but there's a very common pitfall here
by default the loss assumes
the output is probabilities from a soft
max layer
but what our model has actually output
is the values before the softmax these
are often called the logits or logits
you saw these before in the video about
pipelines
if you get that this wrong your model
won't train and it'll be very annoying
to figure out why
in fact i'm going to go so far as to say
that if you remember absolutely nothing
else from this video
remember to always check whether your
model is outputting logits or
probabilities
and make sure your loss is set up to
match that so this is going to save you
a lot of debugging headaches in your
career that would otherwise be very
difficult to track down and very
annoying
but leaving that aside the second thing
compile needs to know is the optimizer
you
want in our case we're going to use adam
which is sort of the standard optimizer
for deep learning these days
the one thing you might want to change
is the learning rate
and to do that we'll need to import the
actual optimizer rather than just
calling it by string
so much like we did with the loss but we
can talk about that in another video and
i'll link that below
for now let's just try training the
model
so how do you train the model well if
you've used keras before
this will all be very familiar to you
but if not let's look at what we're
doing here
fit is pretty much the central method
for keras models
it tells the model to break the input
into batches and then train on it
so the first input is tokenized text
you'll almost always be getting this
from a tokenizer and if you want to
learn more about that process
what exactly does these inputs look like
uh please check out our videos on
tokenizers and again there'll be links
for those below
so those are our inputs but then the
second argument is our labels and this
is really straightforward this is just a
one-dimensional
numpy or tensorflow array of integers
and they correspond to the classes for
our examples
and that's it so if you're following
along with our data from our data sets
video
there'll only be two classes so this
will just be a vector of zeros and ones
but you can have many more classes than
that for your own problems
so once we have our inputs and our
labels we do the same thing with the
validation data
we pass the validation inputs and the
validation labels in a tuple
and then we can if we want to specify
details like the batch size for training
and then you just pass the whole thing
to model.fit and you let it rip
so if everything works out you should
see a little training progress bar as
your loss goes down
and while that's running you you know
you sit back you call your boss and you
tell them you're a senior nlp machine
learning engineer now and you're going
to want a salary review next quarter
so this is really i'm kidding a bit but
this is really all it takes
to apply the power of a massive
pre-trained language model to your nlp
problem
but could we do better than this like is
there any changes we could make so there
certainly are
there's a few more advanced keras
features like a tuned scheduled learning
rate we could get an even lower loss
and an even therefore an even more
accurate model and also
when we when fit finishes what do we do
with our model once it's trained so
these are all topics
i'm going to cover these and more in the
videos and again i'm going to link those
subsequent videos below